MISKO HEVERY: Hi, my name
is Misko Hevery.
I'm the father of AngularJS.
BRAD GREEN: And I'm Brad
Green, and I will play
Angular's manager today.
It's what I do.
All right, so we wanted to take
some time in front of you
folks-- thanks for coming, by
the way-- talking about what
it is that drove us
to build Angular.
Because we think, when people
come and look at the Angular
framework, a lot of times they
see the features of Angular,
and maybe we're not very clear
about what we meant.
When they come to see the
features, they see what we
call the three D's--
directives, dependency
injection, and data-binding.
But we're passionate about some
very different things.
We just happened to arrive at
these features along the way.
So Misko, why don't you talk
about what do you care the
most about web development?
MISKO HEVERY: So web
development, if you think
about it, is all about getting
data to the browser, and then
back to the database.
And so one of the things that
you end up doing is a whole
lot of boilerplate marshaling
of the data back and forth.
And after you build a couple
of web applications, you're
just getting tired of writing
the same thing
over and over again.
And it's kind of getting in the
way of just building the
actual stuff.
And so, the boilerplate is one
of the things that we really
wanted to eliminate as
much as possible
inside of our codebase.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
So we thought that if we can
distill our apps-- if we could
boil them down, maybe--
to their essence, about just
what adds value to the app,
then it'd be very much--
it's easier to build these
applications, but also easier
to understand.
We spend a lot more time reading
code than writing it.
So we thought that
would be cool.
MISKO HEVERY: So the next
thing is, every single
application I've ever been
on, it was structured
in some other way.
And having a common way of
structuring the application
means the developer
can easily bring--
come up to speed on your
codebase, and we can easily
move between projects.
And so giving structure to the
applications is another
important thing.
BRAD GREEN: What is
that shape, Misko?
MISKO HEVERY: That's
a scaffolding, sir.
BRAD GREEN: Do you know how
to draw scaffolding?
MISKO HEVERY: No.
I do not get paid to draw.
I get paid to write code.
BRAD GREEN: OK, good thing.
Good thing.
MISKO HEVERY: And then lastly,
I'm a big fan of testability,
and so we put a lot of testing
effort into our framework.
But it's not enough to just
build a framework
which itself is tested.
It's all about making sure
that the people--
developers writing code, using
the framework will have easy
time testing.
And so one of things we wanted
to make sure is the way the
framework is structured
naturally leads you down the
stability path
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
And we believe that if you're
shipping software, you better
be shipping tested software.
So we really wanted
to make that easy.
So let's go back to a few years
to 2009, where I think I
said, Misko, you should
go learn JavaScript.
This seems like the new thing.
And what did you do?
What was your first inclination
as a newbie in the
world of JavaScript?
What did you do?
MISKO HEVERY: Well,
write a framework.
What else would you do?
BRAD GREEN: That's right,
every newbie
should write a framework.
It's a good policy.
MISKO HEVERY: So the idea behind
Angular-- the original
Angular was actually a little
different, which was that
there's a lot of web designers
out there, people who are not
really programmers, developers
per se, but they know how to
put HTML together because
it's so declarative, and
it's easy to do.
And so, could we enable the web
designers to be able to
build a very trivial, simple
application just by a dropping
little bit of extra markup
logic into the HTML?
So you don't even have to
manage your backend.
You have some database in the
cloud, and you include the
script tag, put a little bit
of extra tags, and all of a
sudden, your form becomes
persistable form and can send
email, and things
of that sort.
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
You know, this eye-stabbingly
yellow logo, right?
MISKO HEVERY: You have something
against yellow?
BRAD GREEN: I got better.
MISKO HEVERY: All right.
BRAD GREEN: All right, so fast
forward just a little bit to--
we were on a project together.
And I remember Misko--
this was a project
called Google Feedback.
And Misko, you and the other
developers on the project were
kind of unhappy with our
development pace?
MISKO HEVERY: Yes.
The velocity was not so great.
We spent about six months, three
of us working on this
particular project.
17,000 lines of code later, we
were really not making the
progress we wanted to make.
And so we're frustrated.
And so in my frustration, I went
to Brad, and I said, you
know, Brad, I'm working on this
thing in my free time,
kind of an open source
project.
And I bet you I could rewrite
the whole thing in two weeks.
BRAD GREEN: And I said, go for
it, because two weeks--
whatever.
But I don't think you quite
made it in two weeks.
MISKO HEVERY: No, I didn't
make it in two weeks.
It took me three weeks.
And 1,500 lines of code later,
we actually have rewritten the
whole application.
BRAD GREEN: I was impressed.
And this was kind of the start
where I though, well, Angular
seems like it could be a thing
unto itself, not just a part
of Google Feedback as
the way it was.
And this is where we decided we
would spin it off into its
own entity.
MISKO HEVERY: So what exactly
is it to build a single-page
application?
Well, you have a database, and
you the browser, and the stuff
in the middle is really what
we're talking about, right?
And so to have a single-page
application is really all
about modifying the DOM-- you
know, the divs, the spans, the
uls, the lis, the tables,
and so forth.
You need to transfer it from
one state to another state,
because that essentially
is going to drive
the rendering engine.
But the thing that's different
between [? round-tree ?]
applications and single-page
applications that you have to
deal a lot of it about the
internal thing called RAM.
BRAD GREEN: Memory.
MISKO HEVERY: Memory.
Memory, I see.
BRAD GREEN: We call it
memory these days.
MISKO HEVERY: So the heap
of the program, right?
So instead of getting the data
in line with your HTML to get
data separately, you load
it into the memory.
And now the problem becomes once
we get it to memory, how
do we get it to the DOM?
And then back when the user
interacts into the memory, and
into the database?
And so our passion really became
how do we simplify this
flow of data to the DOM, and
back to the database.
And this is essentially
what became Angular.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
And we got a logo.
But let's see how this works.
And we're going to go to an
example of the basics of
moving back and forth.
And this is one of
those three D's--
and we'll actually describe
them-- not our goals.
But it's important.
So data-binding, the
way this works.
We've got a--
just in a template, we're
actually able to express kind
of an interesting case.
Well, let's actually see how
this works before we
dive into the code.
So Misko's a text box here,
and you'll notice how he
types, the words that he types
appears below, and the word
"hi" appears when there's
something in the box.
So if he deletes all the text in
the box, the word "hi" goes
away, and we don't
see anything.
So let's go back and take a
look at how this works.
So at the top, you'll notice
in the HTML tag, we have an
extra attribute that
is not actually
part of the HTML spec.
And there-- all these things
in green are--
these are extensions
we've added.
And we call them directives.
But they allow us to assemble
the application
in interesting ways.
And here on the input field,
what we've said is that the
model for our data-- the place
in memory where this lives--
we're going to name it with an
object called "user," and we
have a property called "name."
And that we want this thing
synced up, so that whenever
somebody types that in memory,
it should update this
user.name, and we
can use that elsewhere.
So right below it in the
paragraph tag, we want to
place that text.
So what we do in double
curlies-- we call this
interpolation--
we're able to place that text
right in there just by putting
those double curlies in.
This is a familiar syntax
that's used in other
templatinig languages.
But we're also able to use it
not only to modify what data
is there, but to control whether
it's shown or hidden.
So in the p tag, we have ng-show
equals username.
Well, what this says is that
showing and hiding should be
controlled by presence
of text in there.
If there's no text, hide it.
If there's text, show it.
But we had an interesting eureka
moment in here, which
is that our templating system
was actually HTML, which means
you can use all your existing
HTML editors, such as
Dreamweaver, or your HTML editor
inside of your IDE.
And this is in stark contrast
to most other templating
systems that happen to be
templating languages of their
own, and just happen to produce
HTML on the end.
This is actually HTML
all the way through.
And that makes it easy for
people to pick up and learn,
such as for web developers-- or,
for web designers who are
already familiar with
the HTML paradigm.
BRAD GREEN: That's right, but
data-binding isn't the whole
story, right?
So we also want to put in but
some other bits when we create
an application.
MISKO HEVERY: So at the
beginning, I mentioned the
idea was, could I build a very
simple web application without
having actually any kind
of logic inside--
without having to write any
logic, any program just by
using data-binding?
And if you wanted to build a
real application, sooner or
later you come to the situation
where, well, you
have to put the logic
in there.
And so it's not sufficient to
just have a good data-binding
story, but also have a good
story about how do we manage
all the code that has to be
written, and how does the code
interact with the data-binding,
as well.
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
And let's take a look
at another example.
So here we've got a slightly
more complex example where
we've got two files-- one
index.html on the left, end
UserController.js
on the right.
And again, let's take a look
at how this works before we
walk through the code.
So Misko's going to open his
second tab, and we've got a
text input.
We've got the word
"Larry" in there.
And when he clicks the word--
the bye button, it says, "bye
Larry." Nothing too complex.
But if he changes the text and
clicks bye, it updates to use
"Google I/O" as the text.
OK, let's take a look
at how we do this.
So now, we've got--
we need some logic.
We need some way to take that
text that somebody typed, and
move it somewhere where we can
use in our bye button.
So our template on the left-hand
side, we're adding
another piece to the template.
We are now telling Angular to
construct a template that
relates to some code.
And in this case, we're
specifying that a class called
UserController we're going
to use to manage
this part of the DOM.
And this is some new syntax,
so for people who have used
Angular before, this is some new
syntactic sugar we'll be
releasing tomorrow.
But we're able to create an
alias for UserController.
We're just going to call it
UControl and then we can refer
to it later.
And what we'll see is that we
can put attributes on UControl
that we want to access
as part of our model.
So the input will bind to
UControl.user.first.
And for clicking the button--
when users click it-- it will
specific an ng-click there that
UControl should call the
bye function that we defined
there on the right-hand side.
MISKO HEVERY: But I wanted to
point out something over here,
which is that the UserController
has no access
to the DOM.
There's also no special thing
you have to inherit from, no
special way that you have to
instantiate your model, other
than regular object.
And notice there is no API one
has to call inside of Angular.
This is really just a plain
old JavaScript type that
exists in JavaScript.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
And maybe even more importantly,
notice that
there's no new-- we never call
new on UserController.
We don't create it.
Just by specifying in the
ng-controller tag, Angular
knows enough to create it at
the right moment when this
view comes into my
application.
It creates a controller, and
attaches it-- or, it hands it
the right things in the DOM.
MISKO HEVERY: Right So when
you have a model-view
controller, in Angular,
everything is driven by the
view on the left-hand
side over here.
And the view says I need the
controller, and so the
instantiation of the controller
has to happen,
which then goes ahead and
instantiates the model.
Now the thing to notice over
here is that all of the arrows
point away from the
view, and into the
controller or the model.
And because the arrows point in
this particular direction,
it means that one doesn't have
to start with the view.
One can start with instantiating
the controller
and the model separately.
And this is very wonderful
in tests.
And also, this allows you to
easily reskin your application
for different devices.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
And what this really means is
that my view and my controller
and my model are decoupled,
meaning I could change the
view with the same business
logic and the same model for
maybe different devices,
or different use cases.
So Misko, let's talk about
how this assembly of the
application actually
works then.
MISKO HEVERY: So here, we're
taking a simple case, which we
just saw with the hello world,
and making it a little more
complicated by saying instead
of popping up a dialog box,
maybe we can use a voice
synthesis to actually say the
words that we're about to
display in the LR box.
So in this case, we again need
to have a UserController, but
notice the UserController says
it needs VoiceSynth.
And below, we have a definition
of what Voicesynth
might look like, which then uses
the web audio to actually
speak to-- to generate
the text, and speak
it through the speakers.
And a thing to notice over here
is that the view says it
needs a UserController.
And the dependency injection
system that tries to
instantiate the controller,
but it notices--
a-ha--
but in order to get the
UserController going, I need
to have a VoiceSynth object.
So then it goes one level lower
and says, OK, let me
make one of the voice synth.
But again, it sees, well, I need
a web audio, so it goes
one level further yet,
and it tries-- it
instantiates web audio.
Hopefully, that has
no dependencies.
And then it takes the web audio
instance, puts it inside
of the VoiceSynth instance,
which then is placed inside of
the UserController instance.
And the whole controller is then
handed over to the view.
BRAD GREEN: But let's talk a
little bit about how this
actually works.
Like nowhere in my
UserController do I actually
directly refer to VoiceSynth?
MISKO HEVERY: That's right.
So normally, when you have a
constructor parameter, such as
over here, those don't matter.
I mean, they're only there for
the user-- for the developer
to kind of understand
what's going on.
But in our case, we actually
look at the actual text, and
we use the VoiceSynth key to
match it up against the
VoiceSynth class so that
we can instantiate it.
BRAD GREEN: Right, very cool.
Now this is great for
building my app, and
rearranging my app.
If I go to refactor my
application, this is cool.
But it's also great
in testing.
MISKO HEVERY: That's right.
So let's say we wanted
to test this thing.
So first of all, we probably
don't want to instantiate the
whole HTML5 DOM.
That's expensive.
So we'll start a layer lower,
and we're going to say, well,
that's just instantiated
UserController.
But tests don't hear.
They don't have ears.
BRAD GREEN: They hear
very poorly.
MISKO HEVERY: Yes.
And so we would really like to
do is replace the VoiceSynth--
the actual voice synthesizer--
with a VoiceSynthMock.
And so what we're really
trying to tell to the
dependency injection system is
that we're going to change the
recipe by which you build the
application slightly so that
we can get a subset of the
application going configured
in a slightly different way.
And once we get the subset,
it's very easy to apply
stimulus to it, and assert that
the right methods get
called on a VoiceSynth.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
OK, let's take minute and step
back, and talk about what do
we got so far.
MISKO HEVERY: So we have this
imperative world, and we have
this declarative world,
imperative world being, let's
say I wanted to center
something.
In imperative world, you have
to compute the width of the
page, the width of the thing you
want to center, divide it
by half to get the midpoint,
align the midpoints, and then
render the text that you want.
The trouble with this way of
doing it is when somebody else
comes afterwards and looks at
the code, and they're going to
have to reverse-engineer.
What is the side effect
of this piece of code?
Declarative is, on the other
hand, if you simply say I want
to center to this thing, and
it doesn't matter where the
implementation is.
And actually, the concept of
centering might actually be
implemented slightly differently
in different
browsers, as long as the end
result is the same thing.
And so, up to now, usually when
you have a framework, the
developers really are just, hand
it over, and say, you get
to use this imperative thing--
this is you, you can play with
it any way you want.
But the declarative thing, well,
we'll have the framework
give you some vocabulary for
the declarative stuff, but
it's essentially fixed.
So we thought, wouldn't it be
great if we could take this
vocabulary and extend it.
And this was our a-ha moment,
and saying, hm, why are we in
some way special that we can
create vocabulary, but the
developer can't?
What if we gave the same tools
to the developer, as well?
And so we have a change in
Angular in that the developer
gets to use the imperative or
gets to use the declarative
world, depending on what they
feel like is the best way to
solve this particular problem.
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
Let's take a look at
some examples.
So we've seen how directives can
be used to express the way
we wire our application together
with ng-model and
ng-controller, and the way we
change the structure of the
DOM with ng-show, as we saw.
But you can also use it to
create reusable components.
For example, if I wanted maybe
a star rating component, I
could, after implementing it,
then just use it in my
template by saying,
angle-bracket-rating, and then
pass the data to it that it
needs through its attributes.
You can create more complex
things where you've got
nested, or components that
need to collaborate.
For example, a set of tabs
will have the information
about which one is highlighted,
and which one
should I paint with
a box around it.
And then the individual tabs
inside will contain the title
and the content.
You could also do it not just
by element name, but also by
attribute name.
And so you can create things
like a tool tip, where you
could place it on a span or on
a tab or in a rating, or
anything else in the UI.
OK, we've covered kind of
the basics in Angular.
And now let's take it back to
the way we were kind of
creating apps before we wrote
the Angular framework.
We weren't using jQuery, but
we're going to use jQuery here
because we feel like a
lot of folks know it.
We've got a simple
application.
Misko's going to show us.
MISKO HEVERY: It says you're
going to tap dance, but you
got no shoes.
BRAD GREEN: I took them
off because I knew
that line was in there.
And then we're going to rewrite
the application in
Angular, and show some
of the differences.
MISKO HEVERY: So here's a
very simple application.
All it really does is it shows
you a list of projects.
And what you can do is you can
add, and it brings you to the
detailed view.
Notice when I click the Add,
it's a single-page
application, the URL didn't
actually change.
It's the same URL.
I can say something over here,
hit Save, and now I have my
new item inside of the list.
I can further click on
it, and delete it.
BRAD GREEN: I should mention,
there is a very simple RESTful
server running a node on the
backend here that we used to
persist the project.
MISKO HEVERY: So really,
it's just an
application with two views--
very simple.
And what's strange about this
thing is that it takes me two
sentences to explain what it
does, yet it takes me about
200 lines of both HTML and
JavaScript to actually
implement this.
And so there's a little bit of
a disconnect over there.
So what does this look like?
Well, so this is a
list of projects.
And in this case, we have a
template, which is a table.
And inside of the table head,
we have this plus on the
right-hand side.
And notice what we
have to do here.
We have to say, well, there's a
link-- so that it looks like
a link-- but actually, it
actually goes nowhere.
Inside of JavaScript later on,
I'll show you, you basically
have to set up a click listener,
and we have to
prevent the default behavior of
the browser-- which is to
navigate to a link--
and actually just modify
the DOM to
render the details page.
And this kind of breaks the
paradigm of what a web
application is supposed to be.
And so we'll show you how
Angular can make better usage
of this thing.
The other thing is that in the
table row, the same kind of a
click has to happen, but there's
no-- it isn't clear
what the text goes
inside of here.
And so we actually have to get
a hold of this thing from the
JavaScript side, as well.
We do something similar for the
form for the details view.
So let's have a look at how
is this implemented in
JavaScript.
So the first thing you're
going to notice is that
there's a tremendous number of
selectors that have to get
executed in order to get
a hold of the right
pieces of the DOM.
And what the selectors
essentially end up doing is
they are essentially creating
the arrow going in the
opposite direction from the code
to the view that creates
coupling, and it makes it
difficult for a web designer
to come in and move things
around, and number break the
CSS selectors that
select them.
BRAD GREEN: Even if we're using
IDs, it's still fragile.
It's still something that you
have to be careful about when
you move things around.
MISKO HEVERY: That's right.
And so this basically shows you
how we rendered the page
on the right-hand side.
So we had this show method--
what it does is, well, it has
to assume that there might
have been a different page
before, so it has to remove
the existing content.
It has to add its
template to it.
It has to remove any existing
projects that happened to be
inside of the template before.
And it has to set up this click
listener, which I talked
to you-- mentioned briefly
before, which does the
navigation for one
page to another.
We then go and do an
Ajax to the server.
And for each project, we
basically do clone of the
table row, write the data into
the right locations.
And again, we have to set up
a click listener which
transitions us from the
detail to the--
I'm sorry, from the list view
to the detail view.
And so, what's lost in the
process over here is it's not
clear what this thing
actually does.
There's tons of DOM
manipulation, and the actual
business logic of
this particulate
page is lost in here.
BRAD GREEN: Right.
So let's fast forward,
and let's
reimplement it in Angular.
Let's see how it's different.
MISKO HEVERY: So let's look
at the template again.
What we have done is we have
removed the templates from
index.html and replaced them
with something called a view.
So this is essentially a hole
into which individual pages
will be loaded.
And the actual pages get moved
into a separate file.
BRAD GREEN: Now this template,
the top of the template right
now-- if this was a more complex
application, this is
where we would put maybe are top
nav, or our left-hand nav.
But here it's simple.
We just have one view that
we swap in and out.
MISKO HEVERY: Exactly.
Now notice, instead of
registering a click listener
for this href, we let the href
do what the web does best,
which is create links.
So this case, we're saying,
look, there is a sub-view of
this particular page, which is
the slash project with no ID.
And this is what's
tied to the URL.
So now if I reload this
application, and I click on
the plus, notice that
the URL has changed.
Now a nice side effect of this
is all of a sudden, our back
and forth button just work
without really any effort
whatsoever.
BRAD GREEN: Now, we could have
done that in the jQuery
reversion--
just a lot more work.
MISKO HEVERY: We could have
done it, and it would
be a lot more work.
But this is a model that people
are very familiar with,
that developers are familiar
with, because it's the kind of
round-trip application model,
except the round-trip, it all
happens in the browser.
There's no actual
round-tripping.
This is still a single-page
application that we have here.
So the next thing to notice is
that, instead of manually
making clones on the table
row, we have this other
directive called an ng-repeat,
which basically says for each
project in the list
of projects--
and I'll explain where
the list of
projects comes in a second--
we just want to have a copy of
the TR, and this does the
copying and cloning and managing
it automatically.
The next thing is that all of
the double curlies shown over
here naturally show us where
things belong, so we don't
have to have selectors
to place them there.
And finally, again, we have an
example of deep-linking where,
if you want to click on an Edit
button, it just means
that we want to update the URL
with a specific ID in the URL
that becomes bookmarkable.
And again, all the magic
of bookmarks happens
automatically for us.
So let's look at how this
changes inside of the
JavaScript.
And this is the goal that we
were more after, which was, if
you want to explain to somebody
what this particular
page does, it's just as
simple as saying, give
me a list of projects.
It's a single sentence.
And I want this to be a single
statement inside
of my code, as well.
So in this case, we're saying
we have a project list
controller that is a single
item in there.
So how did we know to load this
particular controller?
Well, if we look over
here, this is
where we set up routes.
We're saying we're emulating
kind of a round-trip
application, but
in the browser.
So we have to say that
when the URL--
which is shown right here--
is a regular slash, we activate
the project list
controller and the project
list template.
And so the project list
controller simply says, go to
the database, and fetch
me a project query.
BRAD GREEN: OK, so
there's something
interesting going on here.
We should explain.
When we query, we're actually
connecting to the database,
but you'll notice, there's
no call-backs there.
What's really going on, Miska?
MISKO HEVERY: So this is a place
where we get to take
advantage of data-binding
in a very unique way.
So project.query query does
essentially an XHR in the
background.
And the way it does this is that
it returns immediately,
but it returns an empty set,
because the server will
respond in some future
point in time with
the actual data set.
And it takes that ng-array,
and just
assigns it to the project.
So when the ng-repeat gets
notified to say, hey, I have a
new data for you inside of the
projects, it simply says, oh,
there's nothing there, and
therefore it renders nothing.
But at some future point in
time, the data actually does
show up, and updates the same
instance of the array, which
then automatically causes the
ng-repeat to unroll itself and
make as many copies of the
project as you have.
So in the simple situation where
all you need is to fetch
some data and render it, we can
actually bypass the whole
need to have a call back.
Now the second thing is, where
did the project come from?
This is where dependency
injection comes in, and this
is how the application actually
gets assembled, which
we kind of mentioned
that earlier.
So right above here, it says a
project can be made by using
something called a resource.
A resource is just a service in
Angular that we can use to
build JavaScript types for the
RESTful backend services.
So we're just saying, this is
going to be a standard RESTful
object, which we can just
use query on to
fetch the data set.
And again, notice that the
application gets automatically
assembled for us.
So just simply by navigating
to the right URL causes the
right route to be activated,
which then activates the right
controller, which then knows to
go and make a new project,
which then knows to build the
project using the resource.
And the whole application gets
assembled without us ever
having to do any
of this stuff.
Similarly, inside of the
project [? details ?]
controller, we can simply say,
show me an existing project or
a new project, depending on
whether we have an ID or not.
BRAD GREEN: So how many lines
of code do we have?
MISKO HEVERY: So we are about
40 lines of code.
And we actually added a new
behavior, because we have
deep-linking available for us.
BRAD GREEN: OK, that's
very cool.
As your manager, however, I need
to ask you to add more
features to this application.
MISKO HEVERY: More features?
OK
BRAD GREEN: Miska, could you
please add more features?
MISKO HEVERY: What feature
would you like to add?
BRAD GREEN: OK, well, thanks.
So this is a list
of projects--
probably frameworks.
People like to write frameworks,
as we know.
It could get long.
How about add the ability to
filter how many frameworks are
there if I want to search
for the one I want.
MISKO HEVERY: So the first thing
you need to add is an
input box, right?
So if I refresh now, I
have an input box.
And if I type into it, this text
actually ends up in the
memory location called
search text.
Now we need to do something
with this particular case.
Now one of things we have-- and
I'm sure you're familiar
with in UNIX-- is the concept of
filters, which we have, as
well as using a simple
pipe-character.
And we can run it through kind
of a special [? mini-ask ?]
functions.
In this case, there's a function
called filter--
I know the naming is
a bit confusing.
BRAD GREEN: I see, yeah.
MISKO HEVERY: But what a filter
does it just looks
through the list of objects in
an array, and sees if any of
the objects happen to have a
text inside of it that matches
the search text criteria inside
of the input box.
So now if I refresh this, you
will see that as I type the
word "web," it will show only
those projects that actually
have the word "web"
inside of them.
Notice how the repeater
automatically grows and
shrinks as the filtering
changes.
BRAD GREEN: OK, very cool.
However, modern applications use
animation to show me-- to
give me a more intuitive
sense of what's going.
Could you maybe animate
the items in the
list in and out as--
MISKO HEVERY: Do you understand
how complicated
animations are?
BRAD GREEN: I don't.
I'm a manager.
MISKO HEVERY: I see.
[APPLAUSE]
So animations--
as you guys all know, I'm sure--
are complex things,
because you have to add things
to the DOM before they
actually come on to stage, then
you have to transition
them to keep track of timers,
remove things, and so on.
And this is where the power of
the declarative world really
comes from.
Because really, what I want to
express to when I'm building
the application is there is
something called animation.
And I want to animate this thing
using a slide animation.
A slide animation is just
something I've declared inside
of my CSS, as this is the set
of transitions we want to
apply to the system.
But actually managing the
DOM's add and removing,
setting the classes at the right
time is actually managed
by this ng-animate directive.
So let's refresh this.
And notice, as I type "web" now,
it removes and adds item
in the correct way with just
a couple of keystrokes.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD GREEN: Sassy.
Very sassy.
All right, so we're kind of at
the end of our coding portion.
Miska has, however, added some
other interesting features
also in sort of a
declarative way.
But we'll just demo them.
You can go to the GitHub
repository.
We'll give you a link at
the end of the session.
But you can also do things like
animate between views.
So if I was on a mobile device,
I would want to be
able to slide back and forth.
We've also done form validation,
so you can have
things that are required, or
that are not really required
but they have to be in a
specific reg-x format, like
something must be a URL.
And these things, as I
mentioned, we can add in also
a purely declarative way.
These are well-understood
problems.
We can just put them
in the template.
So we should talk about a couple
of other things before
we wrap up.
One of the things that
people tell us is
fantastic about Angular--
besides the framework--
is the community.
And there thousands--
hundreds of thousands of folks
in the community who do a
great job of helping each other,
documenting new things
in Angular, adding code,
all kinds of things.
There are meet-ups that
happen regularly.
There are-- on our Google group,
on Twitter, on Stack
Overflow, and Google+.
There's a tremendous
community.
There's an IRC channel that's
very active, too.
As you can see from the map,
there are actually still some
places in the world where we
would love to see monthly
meet-ups, and we'd love to help
you make these happen.
Let's go next.
So the rest of the ecosystem,
Angular kind of fits a small
piece of the whole web
development puzzle.
And I think this is kind of
cool, because it's made space
for other people to create
things that fit in the world.
We've developed some of them,
but a lot of other folks have
created things, too.
So in the world of tools, one of
the things we created is a
Chrome Developer Tools plug-in
called Batarang.
And Batarang lets you visualize
your application,
visualize your data-bindings,
where your template is set up,
optimize the performance,
and debug it--
for all of the Angular-specific
concepts.
The good folks over WebStorm
have created a plug-in that
makes it Angular-syntax aware.
And a lot of us use WebStorm
on the team because of it.
We've been working with Addy
Osmani and Paul Irish and the
other folks on Yeoman to make
it very easy to scaffold an
Angular application, to update
its dependencies, and then to
build and deploy it
when you're ready.
And then, one of our team
members, Vojta, has done
something I think is
extra special.
We talk a lot about testing.
But making the framework
testable was
not the full story.
He wrote a test-runner
called Karma.
And Karma, we think, is the
fastest, most reliable,
easiest test-runner
on the planet.
Matter of fact, I would say
it would change your life.
We should do a demo
of that later.
But it's awesome.
Go download it.
Search for karma test-runner.
It's awesome.
Now when we were talking about
directives, we said that you
can write your own things,
like star ratings and
tabs and tool tips.
And it turns out a lot you don't
want to be doing that.
And so, there are a ton
of directives--
web components--
that you can just use.
And we have things like the
Angular UI Project.
It's not part of Angular but,
they've collected a number of
the web components from
across the web.
And they're specifically a
Twitter Bootstrap theme set of
components.
There are also commercial
versions, like KendoUI and
Wijmo So you can come out of the
box with a whole bunch of
components that you just
snap together like
LEGOs in your template.
In the rest of the world of
libraries, there are things
like BreezeJS that gives you a
very rich set of tools for
manipulating data that comes
from SQL and NoSQL databases.
If you want a database in the
cloud, there's Firebase, who
have created Angular-specific
binding so that you can use
them with our data-binding
system.
And the folks at Salesforce
recently created a developer
tools pack that lets you create
Angular applications
with Salesforce on the backend
on mobile devices.
And then there's books.
I actually--
I wrote one of them, the
one with the fish.
I think that is the most
handsome of the books.
But there--
I think last count, there
are seven books.
Really, you should
buy them all.
I could not choose.
All right, so thank
you everybody.
Thanks so much.
We--
at the lower right-hand side
is the link for our GitHub
repository, for the demos
that you saw today.
Misko and I are available on
Twitter and Google+ if you
want to reach out to us.
We're going to be in the Chrome
Sandbox upstairs for
the next half hour.
We've got a little bit of
time for questions.
But we'll be there.
We'd love to answer questions.
We've got some stickers
to hand out upstairs.
And then Angular books are going
to be in that Chrome
Sandbox area on Thursday and
Friday all day long.
Thank you for coming.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
So, let's go over
here on the mic.
AUDIENCE: So good to
see Angular at I/O.
BRAD GREEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my question is, how
do you configure the curly
braces for data-binding?
That is configurable, right?
I'm using Jekyll with Liquid
templates, and there are curly
braces used there as well.
So I'd like to be able
to configure that.
And do you recommend
against it?
MISKO HEVERY: Yes, so there is a
interpolation provider which
allows you to configure the
starting and ending set of
sequence of characters
that will do this.
And so you could use that.
The caveat is that, if you're
using a third-party library or
third-party widget library that
assumes curly braces, you
might break them.
It's not true?
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, we compensate.
Oh, we fixed it now.
BRAD GREEN: OK, good.
MISKO HEVERY: You can change
it using the--
BRAD GREEN: It just works.
It just works.
Thank you, Igor.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
BRAD GREEN: All right, sure.
AUDIENCE: I come from China
as a [INAUDIBLE]
[? TGD ?]
organizer.
So I notice that a map,
a pocket of all
the Angular's community.
But in fact, AngularJS
[? dot-send ?]
is building just users
[INAUDIBLE].
In fact, in China,
it is very--
so many people like AngularJS.
so my question is how make the
AngularJS community, and you
can address--
you can know it.
I just want to--
I think you [? might ?].
You're not quite [? sure? ?]
BRAD GREEN: I'm kind of
missing the question.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to say [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MISKO HEVERY: I think he's
saying there's an awesome
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRAD GREEN: You're saying in
China, there's a fantastic
JavaScript community, and
there's AngularJS going on.
AUDIENCE: But we lost
it in your map.
So I have a question, why--
BRAD GREEN: Ah.
Tell me where it should go,
and I'll put it on my map.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah, that
would be awesome.
Thank you, thank you.
AUDIENCE: How is Google using
AngularJS internally?
Are there going to be
apps that we use?
Or that consumers use?
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
We've built a lot of internal
apps on Angular.
Google Feedback was
one of them.
The two big external
applications that we've built
on top of it is DoubleClick,
which makes
some money for Google.
This is display advertising.
I mean a lot, actually.
And then YouTube has
built their--
it's kind of like an embedded
in the PlayStation 3
application.
So the live player that you get
with PlayStation 3, that's
built in Angular.
There's some more stuff
on the way.
Can't pre-announce it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because that's
always a concern that you guys
keep using it so that it
keeps growing, right?
BRAD GREEN: Indeed, indeed.
It's well-loved within Google.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRAD GREEN: Thank you.
And over here.
AUDIENCE: First question
is, the query--
it does have a call back,
though, right, if I need it?
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
You can have a call back
if you want to.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah, for catching
errors, and there's some other
reasons you might want
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And secondly, we think
Google-- is there any
sort of internal fight
with Backbone?
BRAD GREEN: There's actually
no fight with Backbone in
terms of Google.
No.
There's none.
None whatsoever.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes.
I just started using Angular for
the first time actually a
couple of weeks ago.
BRAD GREEN: Thank you.
Awesome.
AUDIENCE: And I absolutely
freaking love it.
MISKO HEVERY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So--
BRAD GREEN: Next question.
Awesome.
No, go.
AUDIENCE: The search
functionality, it's really nice.
But can you talk a little bit
about patterns to use when the
data set is big, and it
needs to be paged in
and out, and how--
what's the right way of setting
up your services?
MISKO HEVERY: I think that's
way beyond what we
can answer on stage.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
I mean, I can point you-- there
are several services
that help doing this, for help
doing the pagination, and
doing sort of an infinite scroll
effect, which is what
folks often want.
AUDIENCE: The search, the
actual search, right?
The ng-search stuff.
Not just the scrolling,
but the actual--
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
So that as you type.
You want it like the Google
homepage search style thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, even
if I set up like a
backend search stuff.
BRAD GREEN: As Misko said,
there are some details--
maybe come up to the Chrome
Sandbox, and let's have
a chat about it.
MISKO HEVERY: Yes.
That's a better way of-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah Over here?
AUDIENCE: OK, first of all,
thank you for making Angular.
You saved my bacon like two
months ago making a site.
It's really awesome.
Two questions.
First, what are your
recommendations towards search
engine optimization for sites
built with Angular?
And the other one is, I'm
currently trying to get a site
done in Angular, but the manager
is concerned about
users who don't have JavaScript
enabled, or what--
MISKO HEVERY: What year
is this again?
BRAD GREEN: I think it's 2002.
But no-- so I can't help your
manager, because he is living
somewhere else.
But as far as--
what was the first question?
AUDIENCE: SEO.
BRAD GREEN: SEO, yeah.
So there's a recipe for SEO.
There's a website called
"Year Of Moo." It's
this guy named Mateo.
He worked with us on the
animation directive actually.
And he is a very
good documented
path for doing this.
Search for "Year of
Moo" angular SEO.
MISKO HEVERY: And it has to
do with the headless--
BRAD GREEN: Using PhantomJS to
kind of render your pages.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And that wouldn't be penalized
by you guys, as Google?
Because--
BRAD GREEN: No.
AUDIENCE: Since users are--
BRAD GREEN: There's no way
for Google to know.
We see what you finally
render.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK Thank you.
BRAD GREEN: Sure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we already built a
map with Backbone and other
stuff, and we don't have a--
it's like a financial app.
So now, do you think I could
introduce Angular and, with
it's help-- because it's a huge
app, a trading app, but
lot of Backbone, and a
lot of stuff in it.
BRAD GREEN: So what is the
core of the question?
Could you rewrite in Angular?
AUDIENCE: I mean, do I have
to only rewrite something?
Or will it-- can I use
this as a part of it?
Or how will this help--
MISKO HEVERY: Yeah.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
is [INAUDIBLE] do a
full rewrite, or
you can do it partially.
And one of the things we wanted
to make sure that
Angular plays nicely with other
frameworks so that you
could rewrite an app one
page at a time, or
something like that.
So there's even--
I've seen some blog posts about
people trying to get
Angular to run together
with Backbone.
So they'll use Backbone for the
models, and Angular for
the data-binding
and rendering.
So that should be possible.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because we use
data-binding of the Backbones.
Thanks.
MISKO HEVERY: I think we can
make time for one more
question, and then time
is running out.
BRAD GREEN: Yes.
Right over here?
And we'll hit the rest of
you up in the sandbox.
AUDIENCE: All right,
score for me.
So I actually have been using
it for the past half
year, and loving it.
I have two very specific
questions about ng-switch.
So one of them is, lately I've
been doing a lot of nested
ng-switches.
One inside--
like for instance, one is true,
and inside that another
ng-switch, and sometimes
a third.
Should I be concerned about
doing nested ng-switch?
That's question number one.
MISKO HEVERY: If you're just
going to nest just a few
ng-switches, it shouldn't
be an issue.
If you're gonna nest 50 of them,
then maybe you should
look at a different
way of doing it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
That's good to know.
So the second one is, is there a
good way to do undefine with
ng-switch, because I haven't
been able to do that very
successfully.
So what I always have been doing
is to actually have the
wrapper do a return
true or false.
And then have it go to web
[? branch ?] when true, and
then when false--
versus when I tried to do one
undefined, it just doesn't
seem to fall to the
right branch.
So not sure if anybody else has
seen this similar problem.
BRAD GREEN: I didn't
quite get it.
But maybe let's continue
this back upstairs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
Cool.
BRAD GREEN: Thank
you everybody.
MISKO HEVERY: Thank you
BRAD GREEN: Thanks so
much for coming